Ronda
santis had something great come out over
the weekend which is he answered the
call to defend Tommy tuberville Tommy
tuberville the Republican senator who is
holding up Joe Biden's military
promotions because the Pentagon decided
to push a radical pro-abortion policy
the Pentagon decided that they were
going to take taxpayer dollars and pay
service members to to go to different
states to fly to different states to
kill their children through abortion
because the dobs decision from the
Supreme Court limited the Constitutional
license to abortion so after dos comes
out after roie Wade is
overruled the Pentagon top Rass they say
hey it's really really important to be a
fighting force it is really really
important that we pay our service
members to kill their own children no
matter how difficult it is even if they
have to fly across the country we are
going to pay our service members to to
kill their own children which seems
contrary to the purpose of the military
the purpose of the US military is to
protect us and kill our
enemies the the purpose of the US
military is not to kill our own children
that would be to my mind the very
opposite of the purpose of the US
military so Tommy tuberville heroically
stands up and says you're not getting
your promotions you're not getting more
top brass out there at the Pentagon
until you roll back this policy we are
still a government of the People by the
people for the people I am an elected
representative of the people we're not
going to let you wacko far- leftists who
have infiltrated the US military the
last conservative institution in America
we're not going to allow you to spend
our money without any oversight to this
evil evil end and a bunch of the
squishes have turned against Tommy
tuberville but Ronda santis just came
out and defended him do you agree that
Tommy tuberville should lift the
blockade on Military promotions do you
agree with Republicans in the Senate
actually I think that what the dod is
doing I don't think they're following
the law with respect to the abortion
tourism I don't think taxpayer money
should be spent on that uh we have a
very weak defense industrial base we've
got huge problems with recruiting and so
their focus on that I don't think it's
consistent with the law I also think
it's misguided I would also point out
that you can promote people um on an
individual basis I think the Senate has
decided they have not wanted to move a
lot of those uh but if there's people
that are mission critical uh they can
move it um in spite of what Senator
tubble did but I think fighting back on
the Pentagon going outside the
boundaries of the law I think that's
congress's appropriate role for
oversight and checks and balances But to
answer the question do you think that
Senator taborville should lift the
blockade that he's put on Military
promotions no because I think that he
we're trying to force a change in
Pentagon policy to conform them to the
law while at the same time he has
allowed individuals to be to be
appointed uh so if there are mission
critical promotions bring them before
the Senate I think he's been very clear
that that's a appropriate and I know
that they have done that um in certain
instances totally right on finally
finally you're hearing a republican in
elected office in this case someone
who's running for president say the
obvious Tommy tuberville is a hero this
is an excellent excellent move by him
very courageous and the squishes who are
standing on the sidelines keeping their
mouth shut while the top Rass of the
Pentagon transforms our military into an
American baby killing machine can you
imagine
and and the the even worse the squishes
on the Republican side who are attacking
Tommy tuberville those those people
deserve
contempt in public
life danant is totally right here and I
want to hear more Republicans saying it
why is it taking the governor of Florida
the number two guy in the presidential
race to to be among the first prominent
Republicans to defend tuberville I want
to hear every elected Republican defend
Tommy tuberville now that was good stuff
I'm very very happy with DeSantis for
this unfortunately uh Governor DeSantis
followed that answer with a very bad
answer also on MSNBC right now text
nolles to 998 9898 yet again we're
facing the threat of a government
shutdown and of course the
administration will deal with it the
same way they always do with more
spending which will inevitably devalue
the dollar protect your savings by
diversifying into gold with the help of
Birch gold group when you open an IRA
with Birch gold for every 10 ,000 you
spend by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar just text
nolles kwes to 9898 98 to claim
eligibility before Black Friday Birch
gold can even help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
without taking any money out of pocket
and you still get the free gold bars
with an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied customers you can count on
Birch gold to help you transition an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
do not let your savings fall victim to
the further devaluation of the dollar
text nolles to 998 9898 receive a free
infokit on gold and claim your
eligibility before Black Friday to
receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles kW to
98 98 98 and the answer was what should
happen to president Trump if he is
convicted in any of these show trials
brought by the liberal regime do you
really believe that than a man who's
convicted of say attempting to overturn
the 2020 election or taking nuclear
secrets back to his Beach Club do you
actually still as we sit here today
believe that person should be president
so I signed a pledge uh Willie and uh
that that pledge is what it is now do I
think somebody under those circumstances
could get elected president the answer
is no um that will not happen I think
that Republican voters uh will
understand that as as we get closer to
to to voting uh but it is it would be
fatal in a general election and I don't
think the party should should nominate
in that
situation
okay I guess DeSantis needs to give this
answer I guess because DeSantis is
running against Trump so he wants Trump
out of the primary DeSantis is running
against Trump he needs to convince
voters that Trump is not electable under
any
circumstances and it's easy to say
especially when teed up by an MSNBC host
that if Trump is convicted by the very
very legitimate courts and trials that
are bringing him up on very serious
charges not a complete Banana Republic
show trial stalinesque nonsense no no
this is all very serious Donald Trump
one time it looks like he may have
jaywalked in New York City can you
imagine send him to the gulags for 150
years I guess jandus needs to give that
answer because he's running against
Trump but it's a very bad
answer because it accepts the premise
the liberal premise that these trials
are somehow legitimate they're
not they're not part of the evidence
that the trials are not legitimate other
than the content of these trials other
than how unprecedented it is that a
former president and current leader of
an opposition party of the M of the
opposition party would be indicted the
federal level at the state level over
supposed crimes that have never been
prosecuted against a president that that
the former opponent of Donald Trump with
far less right certainly committed more
clearly than Donald Trump ever did in
the case of Hillary Clinton's classified
email
Scandal it accepts the premise that this
is all somehow legitimate instead of the
show trial that it is and that's no good
because not only do Republican voters
know that this is a political
persecution almost entirely divorced
from the law many Democrats know that
too polls of whether or not Donald Trump
is being politically persecuted through
these trials show a clear majority of
Americans that means including
Independents and
Democrats believe that it's a political
persecution so then you've got you've
got DeSantis I guess necessarily from
his
standpoint echoing left-wing talking
points pretty crucial leftwing talking
points even justifying implicitly the
show trial of Donald Trump
and the principle that a former
president and current leader of of the
opposition party so long as he's a
republican could be prosecuted for this
nonsense very very bad and it once again
speaks to The Impossible position D
santis is in which is that desantis's
whole candidacy is premised on being
Donald Trump 2.0 bigger better faster
stronger more articulate more focused
more this you like the original you're
going to love the new version that's the
that's the whole
pitch even the way that the desandis
campaign is speaking now they're saying
Donald Trump he's not the man he was in
2016 that's the new talking point from
the disantis campaign and I I guess it's
the best one they've got but that only
doubles down on the notion that Dan
santis is Trump 2.0 yeah we love Trump
2016 but I'm going to be the real Trump
2016 the current Donald Trump of 2023
2024 he's just he's lost a step he's not
what he promised us he would be I'm the
Fulfillment of the Trump promise okay
well if that's the case you're going to
turn off the moderates and the squishes
and the establishment people in the in
the
GOP
but you're you're probably not going to
pull enough Trump people over so then
you've got to you got to go on over and
sort of side with the squishes and the
moderates and the establishment people
and you got to go on MSNBC and you got
to make that case and that's going to
involve echoing some of the lib talking
points that are totally going to turn
off the Trump people so you're left
even though you're seemingly the the
strongest candidate in the race because
you've got all the Trump bonafides but
you're you're also more polished and
clubbable so you appeal a little bit
more to the people who just simply don't
like Trump's temperament and personality
you go from looking like the strongest
guy in the race into a man without a
home into a man without a country which
is I think being reflected in the polls
and it's unfortunate because the guy's
pretty solid but he's just in I think an
impossible situation boy what Great Clip
that was now hey hey hold up ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael nlls
YouTube channel we'll see you next time